commerce vandalisé et voiture détruites
tout au long de la nuit du 28 au 29 juin
des violences ont éclatées dans la
commune de Trappes ces émeutes font
suite à la mort du jeune Naël tué par un
policier lors d'un contrôle routier à
Nanterre le 27 juin victime de ce chaos
cette boutique de meuble installée
depuis 4 ans dans le quartier des
Merisiers a été en partie incendie avec
de l'essence le giron appelle les jeunes
à ne pas se faire justice eux-mêmes on a
été très choqués pourquoi parce que on
fait partie de Trappes on a grandi ici
on a essayé de développer une activité
ici pour les gens de Trappes pour eux
pour les familles et voilà d'avoir ça au
retour ça fait mal au cœur et j'ai envie
de leur dire que ça sert à rien de de
mettre le feu comme ça dans tout trap
essayer de de calmer les choses une
centaine de mètres plus loin des
poubelles ont également été incendiées
devant l'hôpital privé de Trappes créant
de léger dysfonctionnement en interne
s'attaquer au bien public non c'est pas
franchement
une bonne idée cette personne au final
et c'est je trouve ça dommage
aujourd'hui ces habitants espèrent un
retour rapide de la paix dans cette
commune de 34000 habitants laissez-nous
tranquille nous sommes dans une ville
populaire solidaire où il fait bon de
vivre à Trappes moi j'adore ma ville je
vis là par choix depuis 30 ans et j'ai
jamais vu ça et franchement j'appelle un
appel au calme là on voit du coup la
haine voilà elles ont la rage et je
comprends je compatis mais c'est pas
pour autant qu'on doit faire des choses
comme ça selon le maire à l'irabel et
dégâts sont estimés à plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros sur
l'ensemble de la commune pour la voirie
seulement